hey guys it's May 26th and you've
probably already noticed that I'm not
just McDonald or even Chris waters I'm
third string News host Mary Kish and for
the rest of the week I'll be giving you
your news stories until there soon but
inevitable return let's get started
first up CD Projekt RED continues to
dominate the hearts of gamers everywhere
by announcing the latest free DLC for
the witcher 3 the developers facebook
page showcased an image revealing a new
contract missing miners where miners
from the small scaliger island are
disappearing I think we both know
they're dead but you'll have to discover
what's eating them and put a stop to it
second is an alternative look for
yennefer fancy it's going to be free and
it's coming to consoles later this week
in all CD Projekt RED plans to release
16 free expansions for the witcher 3 and
then most likely use all their newfound
popularity to rule the world while we're
talking witcher there's a patch
currently rolling out for ps4 with xbox
one shortly after it should improve
performance and cutscenes and gameplay
and add visual tweaks like blood
particles appearing on water surfaces
and correcting that pesky incident
loading screen that caused me to lose 20
minutes of my life last night if you
were upset to hear that rise of the Tomb
Raider is an xbox one exclusive your
prayers have been I Rana CLE answered
via Xbox overlord Phil Spencer's tweet
it's still just temporary Phil Spencer
cleared up some confusion regarding the
exclusivity status of the upcoming
adventure game rise of the Tomb Raider
on Facebook Xbox Australia stated the
game was Xbox exclusive not time
exclusive but exclusive exquisite but
Phil quickly stamped out the fire on
Twitter stating same as before when i
answered timed for now it's possible
rise of the Tomb Raider can come out on
playstation 4 and or PC although there's
been no official statement so far until
dawn made headlines for a few reasons
today first they announced their release
date which is August 25th but second and
more importantly they got that guy from
the big lebowski to be in the game
developers supermassive games announced
the playstation 4 horror game until dawn
will launch in north america on august
plaintiff following up that they're
adding celebrity actor peter stormare
who you might recognize from Fargo the
big lebowski and jurassic park the lost
world and any other movie requiring a
creepy dirty Swedish sociopath I dare
you to say that three times fast he's
the third celebrity after to join the
game hayden Panettiere and Grammy Malik
will now be cast in the dark shadows of
his talent contrary to popular belief CD
Projekt RED can't always give you what
you want and this week they announced
that they're not going to be giving any
more information on cyberpunk 2077 for a
couple years CDP our CEO Adam Kaczynski
raised our hopes by saying he expects
cyberpunk 2077 to be a bigger commercial
success than the witcher 3 then stopping
on them by saying they won't be talking
about the game until 2017 at the
earliest now that's a tease cyberpunk
2077 puts players into a dark future
where advanced technologies have become
both the salvation and the curse of
humanity the game will offer a nonlinear
story designed for mature players and is
set in the metropolis of night city it
will also have sandbox elements and some
form of multiplayer those CD Projekt RED
stresses that cyberpunk 2077 is an RPG
if you want more info than that you'll
have to cryogenically freeze yourself
until 2017 and that's all the news we
have for you today but be sure to check
back to gamespot tomorrow we're also be
here because unlike my co-workers I've
used up all my vacation days see you
then